let's include christopher hitchens of
Vanity Fair and Republican pollster
Frank Luntz Fred Barnes of the Weekly
Standard moderates this forum hosted by
the American Enterprise Institute
ladies and gentlemen we're ready to
start the second panel of today which
will focus on the next Congress on
behalf of the American Enterprise
magazine I'd like to thank our
distinguished panelists for coming today
and it's also my pleasure to introduce
their ringmaster Carlin Bowman she's
famous as Washington's premier Paul
Meister she's a resident fellow with the
American Enterprise Institute an opinion
opinion false editor as well for the
American Enterprise magazine under whose
auspices these talks are taking place
today
her latest book co-authored with Everett
Carl Ladd is public opinion in America
and Japan how we see each other and
ourselves and of course she's a regular
panelist with AEI is popular election
watch Series Carlin thank you very much
Scott I'd like to add my welcome to all
of you to the American Enterprise
magazine's roundtable on the next
Congress let me take just a moment to
briefly introduce our panelists as you
probably noted by this time Fred Barnes
is missing in action at this point he's
circling around Baltimore we think the
rains have kept him from being here and
we're hoping that he'll be able to join
us a little later in this session to my
left but certainly not politically as
Mike Farris a known to many of you is
the Republican candidate for lieutenant
governor of Virginia in 1993 and now
very very active and president of the
home school Legal Defense Association
Mike is also founder of the Madison
project which raises money and provides
volunteers for like-minded Republican
candidates and he's just told me about
something that's coming up in the next
month I hope all of you will watch for
the debut of his novel anonymous tip in
November first about to the first of
October I look forward to that
Christopher Hitchens on his left is a
columnist for the nation and also for
Vanity Fair a prolific journalist in
both the United States and England and
his books include for the sake of
argument blood class and nostalgia Anglo
American ironies and his latest book the
missionary position a book about Mother
Teresa
Franklin's to my right is the president
of lunch research in the pollster of
record
for the contract with America in 1992 he
was named one of the 50 rising stars in
American politics by campaigns and
election magazines and has I think the
very impressive distinction of having
won the Washington Post crystal ball
competition award for the most accurate
pundit in 1992 last but not least on his
right is Grover Norquist president of
Americans for Tax Reform he writes a
regular column for the American
Spectator the politics column and his
also author of the very successful rock
the house a book that described the
change the massive change that we saw in
congressional elections in 1994
Grover I'd like to begin with you this
morning by asking you a broad question a
number of observers have suggested that
this this fall's congressional elections
will be among the most important in the
country's history is that just election
year hyperbole or is there more at stake
in this election than usual well for the
house and the Senate I think there is
but particularly the house if the
Republicans maintain control maintain
their majority in the house you're
looking at a situation where the
Republicans could keep that majority for
20 or 30 years because not only this
election where I think the Republicans
will actually pick up seats even if
Clinton runs a strong presidential race
but two years from now their whole
series of Democrats in marginal or
Republican seats that are hanging around
to see if the Democrats are coming back
into power and if they don't I think
across the south and the Midwest you
have a second tier of retirements coming
that will even will solidify the
Republican control and you could see it
continue for 20 or 30 years with no
reason to see the Democrats able to come
back to take control of the house if you
have 51 votes in the Senate you don't
control the Senate but if you have 51%
of the house you have to control the
house so that the house is more
important than the Senate in terms of
maintaining control and I would argue
this election will decide who runs the
house for the next 20 years
Chris would you agree is this an
historic election yes I do think so I
I'm in the weird position of wanting to
recommend a piece that some of you may
have read and all of you ought to in no
commentary magazine
by Daniel Cass it's called party of one
it's a study of mr. Clinton's
relationship to this Congress and the
next one mr. Castle I don't know worked
in the bush White House and also
directed that for his sins the Lamar
Alexander campaign but what he what he
point I'll just if I'm out just quite a
little from this very suggestive piece
what he says and what I've got every
reason to think is true from
conversations with members of the
Clinton entourage is that the truly
emancipating moment for the Clinton
presidency came when the Democrats were
destroyed in that in the house that that
allowed him to be a unbearably light to
rise clear of his party and I think it
will be found in general to be true that
he will do well when his party does
least well and that for him this was a
really essential so to speak defeat well
just quote if I may mr. Cash's
conclusion far from trying to rebuild
his party Clinton is trying to decouple
the presidential engine from the
Congressional Train he has learned how
the Republicans can be at once a steady
source of new ideas and a perfect foil I
think that's very well and pungently put
I think the counterpart to it probably
holds true as well which is the best
test of a hypothesis if you pretend just
for the moment there's and gentlemen for
an exercise to be Newt Gingrich you
imagine yourself to be mr. English get
up in the morning be mr. English come
down to breakfast see mrs. Gingrich
there that kind of thing
actually be him what do you who do you
want to be president in the fall
obviously you don't want a mediocre
senile moderate Republican once you want
is Bill Clinton from your point of view
to be the first and I think that
probably all the start all the sides in
this argument which fees is me because
it makes non sense of the current
formulaic style of bipartisanship my my
view of that is always as with mr. Perot
the difficulty in starting a third party
in this country is that there are not
yet two parties I think that this
election will probably be the first so
to speak bipartisan election
the new style and will lead to that kind
of a Congress that would emancipate us
in turn from the idiotic donkey elephant
discourse that's dominated everything
from her bloc cartoons to crossfire for
so long I can't personally wait Frank
would you agree is it a fundamental
realignment I wonder if you could try to
put that in perspective by talking a
little bit about the country's mood and
what what people are thinking about is
they cast their votes this fall well
this is the continuing efforts in post
partisan politics fact is that 1992 was
really the first election where
Republicans and Democrats didn't matter
so much you know we did this instant
response work for ABC News where we
tested speech after speech at the
Republican and Democratic conventions
and one of the things we found is just
mentioned the word Republican lines went
down mentioned the word Democrat lines
went down people don't want to hear
about Republicans and Democrats anymore
you have to be 60 years of age or older
or a member of Grover's family to be
really partisan at this point that the
public has really come to reject in that
style now it's not to say that they've
rejected the ideology of the Republican
Party or the Democratic Party they just
don't like party labels and Clinton has
done a admirable job as now speaking as
an observer in blurring the distinction
between Republican and Democrat he truly
sounds like a Republican or like a
Republican would have say 10 15 years
ago and in fact if you watched his
Memphis speech even better than his
convention his Memphis speech where his
arms are draped over the podium and he
looked like he was just having this kind
of fireside Roosevelt style chat and he
went for 35 minutes without a note
without a cue card with nothing talking
about well we need tax cuts but well we
need a balanced budget but while we need
welfare reform but I mean the man he is
the but president of the 1990s but he
has been able to do what Republicans in
a sense have not been able to do up to
this point which is blur a lot of
distinctions and move across towards the
independence kind of blur the lines and
enable himself to attract voters
in 1994 found him abhorrent and I give
him some credit for that one final point
and that is that the key vote in 1996 is
that Perot vote and those if Republicans
are successful in 96 as they were 94 in
demonstrating that they had something to
appeal to people who aren't partisan at
all in fact they're anti partisan but
want their budgets balanced once their
taxes reduced want welfare reform
desperately want change even more than
Republicans and Democrats do if the
Republicans continue to be the party of
change in congressional races there's no
doubt they'll keep the majority that's
what Clinton's trying to do is trying to
demonstrate that the Republicans are
trapped in the past rather than focused
on the future Mike from your perch in
Virginia do you think party labels mean
a lot less than they have in the past
and if so what are some of the important
cleavages that you see in our politics
that will have an impact on this year's
congressional races well I definitely
think that the party labels are
lessening and importance when I ran for
lieutenant governor three years ago
I carried heavily Democratic areas of
the ninth district of Virginia for
example which is dominated by the United
Mine Workers Union and others and in my
view there is that the people there
believed in three things God gun and
unions and I was right on two out of
three and and so you you can see a
chance for a basic realignment if the
Republicans will realize that this is
coalition politics and we stay true to
each other's coalition's other aspects
of the coalition I was on Jesse
Jackson's show going opposite the United
Mine Workers Union when I was a part of
the the Pat Buchanan campaign and he
started talking about the Equal Rights
Amendment I thought no what in the world
does the Equal Rights Amendment have to
do with the United Mine Workers Union it
really doesn't have anything to do with
them and if you ask the average mine
worker down in the ninth District of
Virginia what is this guy to do with my
my Union he'll say nothing but the
president the UMW was smart enough to
realize that this is part of the
Democrat coalition and he was going to
be loyal to the whole coalition and
we've got some aspects of the Republican
Party that aren't smart enough or
practical enough to realize that we've
got to be loyal to the whole
we've got to be pro-life we got to be
pro-gun we got to be pro free enterprise
we got to be against the United Nations
taking over our troops and so on if we
if we stay loyal to the whole coalition
we can win but when the with the
fiscally conservative socially liberal
Republicans think that we have to move
to the left is it is a move in the
direction of defeat and I agree with
Christopher said about the need to have
two parties in this country and I think
the freshman the Republican Party are
the light of the future that I think
that that's the direction America needs
to go and I think that it will be a long
time winning party if we if we go in
that direction if national leaders are
downplaying party labels will
congressional candidates do the same
thing the smaller is it still much more
important at the Congressional level go
ahead I don't know that people are
running on party labels so much as
they're running on the the contract with
the name the contract taken out and
deconstructed to the ten issues that
were there the the issues that were in
the contract with America in 94 were
simply ten broad brush issues that the
entire Republican coalition didn't and
could agree on and there are also issues
that seventy percent plus support among
people balanced budget amendment a tort
reform crime legislation all of the
Republicans are running on those issues
they passed a number of the welfare
reform the answer that they passed all
of them in the house they move forward
on other some the Senate wouldn't go
with some Clinton vetoed but they can
run on all of those issues and and are
again I think the other the other issue
for the Republicans is there's a series
of things that they've accomplished in
the house in the Senate when the
Republicans ran in the house they said
they were going to have bought it for
the public audit of how the house has
spent its money for the last 40 years
and and they did that they've brought
out a fair amount of interesting stuff
the press hasn't been terribly
understood and how the Democrats have
been spending money in the house over
the last 40 years but by by continuing
that audit and making the spending in
the house represents transparent by
dropping by a third the number of and
cost of committee staffs rather than
saying it's our pork will spend it now
we'll hire all our friends they actually
dropped real numbers of congressional
staff welfare reform package freedom to
farm their whole series of things to
where this administration this Congress
can say this is what we did this is what
we said we do and we and and we did it
and so they can run both on
accomplishments and on the list of
things that they passed at Clinton
vetoed if you want a $500 per child tax
credit you reelect this house and very
specific and very successful
accomplishments and yet they made a
fundamental planning strategic error
which is that they did it all in clumps
the American people right now do not
pick the average American is not
watching us here whenever that this is
on live or whenever this is on the
average American is watching something
else on on ABC NBC Fox whatever during
the convention they were watching
anything but network TV and so you pass
health care reform and welfare reform
and relief for small business all at the
same time and no one heard anything it's
like a lot of noise the house did more
work in the first hundred days of its
with a lot of the accomplishments that
you spoke of but nobody knew that they
had done anything because it was done so
fast so furious Bill Clinton picks an
issue like school uniforms which is
relatively nebulous and stays on it for
two weeks or three weeks jumps on the
tobacco issue it stays on it two weeks
or three weeks the Republican hierarchy
whoever they are go from issue to issue
to issue and the best example is when
the Medicare numbers came out which
proved that Medicare was going bankrupt
much more quickly than people had
expected they held on to that issue for
two days they moved to the balanced
budget amendment for two days then they
moved to drugs for Friday so in a five
day period they had three big time
issues in five days and then they wonder
why no one knows what they've done if
they don't slow down the process they're
not going to communicate effectively
Christopher would you agree with that
was it the packaging of the bundling of
issues or was it something more
fundamental and
is what some have called the radical
nature of the reforms well no I think
it's partly to do with with the the
award of credibility that people will
make to those who are making the point
they may say I agree with what you say
but I don't think you believe it
yourself sort of thing and I think that
the Republican Party of this incarnation
has to suffer from that tremendous tree
because there is perfectly
self-evidently an absolute launch of
conviction in its leadership
aye-aye evolved evolved evolved a
heartless game in San Diego which was to
stop delegates at random in elevators
and men's rooms and places like that
hoping not to have my intentions was
taken or misunderstood and to say can I
just ask you Chris officials here if
Jack Kemp was the nominee in the smile
would stay pasted on at this point the
group cuz the name Jack Kemp was an
upbeat name if James the nominee I would
ask do you think he would pick Bob Dole
as his running mate a smile disappeared
I didn't get anyone to say obviously he
would yes so self-evident that he would
not and the the house of cards aspect of
it I think is what repels people and
they realized that the deck of cards
sustained the matter is what's been put
before them as an issue they tried to
find that your we are trying to find
your g-spot how are we doing it's not
very it's not very persuasive can i
amplify the point that grover made with
a point that i'm stealing from him that
he made to me in the break one
observation in in massachusetts it seems
if we consider the measurements of
opinions be reliable that governor world
is ahead for the senator in much the
same proportion as President Clinton is
ahead for the presidency I think that's
a good sort of microcosmic instance of
the fungibility of the electorate and I
think that there must be at the
presidential level an element of comic
or zeitgeist calculation involved which
is all to do with this bridge to the end
of the century I think we haven't yet
properly counted the or estimated the
impact of the oncoming millennium but I
think subliminally so to speak it's
almost on American to pick for the
Millennium someone who is
older now than Ronald Reagan was when he
first around for example and I've read
findings but I think mr. Nance I'd like
to know if he can confirm them but
actually the older people are the more
suspicious they are of people of their
own vintage they know how crumbly the
situation can get well I mean Bob Dole
made his biggest gains and the
post-convention bounce among the 18 to
34 year olds and the next most among 35
to 49 year old surnames so that while
Reagan's best groups in 1984 he was
getting reelected with the youngest
voters thanked part of that age issue is
that people who became 21 years of age
between 1930 and 1950 a period of
democratic dominance when big government
and big unions and big business fought
big Wars and did big things and and
people thought themselves much more in
terms of large institutions and more
democratic because if you were in the
north of the West you were more likely
to be a Democrat than not coming of age
30 to 1930 to 1950 those people in oust
66 to 86 years of age and so when you
say how come Bob Dole doesn't do better
among older voters that's a more
democratic age cohort and it's also an
age cohort that isn't used to personal
computers they thought that IBM was
going to invent one big computer and
we'd run Social Security and everything
else through it because that's what the
science fiction writers we're saying at
the time that everything was going to be
large and everyone to go work in
factories from 9:00 to 5:00 and in point
of fact we've moved much more towards a
decentralized world in a number of
different ways and that the older age
court is not only out of sync in a
partisan way they're more democratic I
think they're less likely to see Jack
Kemp's way of looking at a dynamic
economy with with tens they're now more
self employed business men and women in
this country than there are labor union
members that's not what somebody who
came of age in 1935 thought the world
would look like if I could pick up on
the age issue relative to the
congressional elections it's my opinion
that the the older Republicans have been
around here for a long time are at least
relatively devoid of conviction compared
to the younger people that are coming up
in the party the people the freshman
class I
was outstanding in terms of their they
believe the stuff they ran on some of
the people that that were surrounding
them really didn't necessarily do that
but I think that the freshman class as a
whole believed it I think that the new
crop of people that are running for the
House and the Senate absolutely believe
what they say and that conviction and
the difference between their beliefs and
the Democrats is stark and I think the
American people really do have a have a
realistic choice between philosophies
when you look at the the younger people
that are running for Congress in the
Senate for the first time this year if
party labels are a lot less important
what are the kinds of cleavages that are
going to be important we've heard a lot
about gender are we gonna have us a side
anymore divided by income by age we've
heard a lot about class politics in this
election Frank whenever I hear the the
concept of cleavage politics after Dick
Morris and Jefferson Hotel it I have a
completely different view I keep
thinking of $200 per hour and I'm
definitely in the wrong business they
will tell you that about triangulation
yes well I don't think it was so strange
that she was on the phone saying that's
Bill Clinton it was when he was on the
phone saying I know that female voice
anyway yes what I think what is age is
going to be an issue look we're gonna do
with Social Security at some point may
not be the next two years can I be the
next four years I don't know when it's
gonna be and I'm scared to death when
it's gonna happen but you've got a
generation out there that is far more
likely to believe in the existence of
UFOs than to believe that social
security will exist when they retire and
it's not just Social Security it's
Medicare it's the whole entitlement
program and their relationship with
government the Generation Xers have
grown up believing that government just
doesn't work that it doesn't function
that it's a hindrance not a help and
it's very different than the older baby
boomers moving up through the FDR
generation and so you will see more
divisions by age as we move into the
next millennium generation you
generational warfare and the interesting
thing is that you also see a gender gap
which is far greater among younger
voters than it is among the oldest
voters that the end is also has to do
with the life cycle
the unmarried professional woman has
nothing in common politically with the
unmarried professional man they just are
completely at opposite ends of the
political spectrum and it takes till
they get together and have that first
child before you start to see a unity of
political ideas when they get together
yeah that's a whole nother question
which I will leave to other people and
so you're gonna see not just an age
difference but you're going to see a
gender / age and a status a life status
difference which will grow with time
rather than shrink Pepi Canon talked a
lot about class differences in his
campaign do you see class believe it I
don't Christopher do you I really don't
accept that at all you know the old
story about the the Rhodes Scholar
the American who meets his Oxford
professor years later at a conference
and the professor says so nice to see
you again we've lost touch what he what
he'd been doing in the American says
well I've been doing a thesis on the
survival of the class system in the
United States and the officer professor
says Earth frightfully interesting I
didn't think they had a class system the
United States guy says well no nobody
does that's how it survives I mean one
of the things that has I've been in this
country over you never been here for 15
years now I think a lot of things have
stopped surprising me completely some
still do the way the people will tell
you about their therapists or their
religious confession upon meeting it
still startles me on United Airlines I
still I guess I'm so a bit amazed even
though I'm in favor of them of the right
to bear arms I am sort of amazed at the
extent to which this right is is evoked
so to speak but the other thing is I'm
really amazed that you can offer a
member of the House or Senate a
common-law bride that the domination of
the thing simply by large bundles of
money and and also by the constituents
the Constitution of it by people who
were to whom that's you know not
entirely foreign to their nature the
number of people earning more
an average of about a million dollars
who already in the legislature is
extremely high and growing it's
increasingly a profession attracting
other those who have money or those who
want to speak the language very easy to
learn if those who have got it I think
that there will be will and should be a
populist revolt against that I hope it
will not be led by fascists like well I
think there is a at least within the
Republican Party where I've spent a lot
of time in the last few years there's a
definite class system and there is a
distrust of people who who come to the
to the party for the purpose of
advancing social conservatism and I was
at a the other Jefferson hotel down in
Richmond Virginia at a luncheon for a
senatorial candidate a few months ago
with very very much the the country club
said of the Republican Party and I said
the most practical thing the Republican
Party could do the practical thing is to
be absolutely committed to the pro-life
cause because we get a clear bump every
time we do that and these people were
all ready to deny my existence for
saying such a thing because it is it is
such is not something that their norm
they normally hear and that in the
circles that they run in the social
circles that they run in and I think
there's a very real problem in the
Republican Party accepting the fact that
if we're going to be successful we have
got to break down the class barriers
that exist we have a winning coalition
available to us but it cuts across a
whole lot of things and and the people
that the John Warner's of this world
simply have got to understand that
people that don't own polo ponies have
the right to be leaders in the
Republican Party as well you see the
division being fatal well it depends on
on the is only one group that can
control that and that is the people that
want to make the cleavage that that want
to make the split within the Republican
Party the the George Bush crowd if you
will want to divide off the the social
conservatives they're the kind of ugly
cousins they want to keep on the back of
the bus and and I think that that until
the whole Republican team is embraced
warmly Republicans will not be a
dominating party we we have the
potential
dominating party because we've got the
right ideas as a coalition but we aren't
loyal to each other's first principles
when we get that message straight then
we're gonna win actually I'd like to
make the counter-argument that I think
the Republican Party today is much more
unified and ideologically coherent than
it was 10 years or 20 years ago when
when you go back to the time of Richard
Nixon in 1968 72 there were Republican
governors at the time who viewed the
role of the governor's to spend more
money and raise taxes we had we had
Millikan and roads and and sergeant and
and big government Republicans and not
just Rockefeller Republicans but Richard
Nixon himself introduced all sorts of
new taxes new regulations wage and price
controls date aunt
I mean if Richard Nixon came back to
life today and was a member of the House
of Representatives as as a Republican
he'd be the most left-wing remember the
Republican caucus I mean Jim leach
wouldn't talk to him I mean he's he's
off the scale now you can also do that
with John F Kennedy coming back the
Democrats wouldn't let him in the room
either but it really does it's
interesting for the Republicans so you
not only have a more conservative
certainly in all the economic issues
anti-tax none of the Republican
governors elected in the 92 and 94 cycle
have turned around and tried to raise
taxes or increased spending or have new
government programs they've all moved in
a Reagan direction
talking to people in the house we got a
majority of the house caucus Republicans
in the house to be Reagan Republicans by
84 it took until 94 to have a Reagan
majority among Republicans in the Senate
this next election when you talk about
how well the Republicans do I think the
Republicans would pick up in both the
house and the Senate but the big gain
will be among Reagan Republicans because
in the in the Senate and in the house
the people who are retiring are the old
Nixon Republicans people from that era
both ideologically and and
chronologically so but look at the
Republican Party they agree on the
contract taxes tort reform spending
issues
SDI foreign policy issues where you have
a debate and I think it's it's a it is
on abortion some of the social issues
you
but when a left-wing Republican wants to
cut the budget deregulate sell off
everything privatize and is pro-choice
on abortion I mean that's not a read
that's not a party that's falling apart
it's a party it's having an argument
about a couple of several important
issues on the social side but look at
the amount of unity and agreement within
the party and growing parties will
always have some divisions I'd I
wouldn't want a party like the kind they
have in Britain with seven members who
agree on everything but they've purged
everybody who didn't agree well I think
it's just a matter of being smart and
being loyal because there are a lot of
us that come to politics that have as
secondary or tertiary points of our
philosophy the issues you outlined but I
wouldn't go to war over any of those
things they don't mean anything to me
what I want to see accomplished in
Congress is to get rid of the National
Endowment for the Arts completely I want
to see the elimination the US Department
of Education completely I want to see
some advancement on the pro-life cause
we don't get the the social
conservatives really are the foot
soldiers that were of the Reagan
Revolution and that's the difference
there are two differences between Barry
Goldwater and Ronald Reagan one is Barry
Goldwater was main Ron Reagan see
eminently nice and the other is Ronald
Reagan brought the social conservatives
and as well as the economic and foreign
policy conservatives and and until the
whole Republican leadership understands
that that we've got to have the whole
team and we've got to be loyal to the
troops if the United Mineworkers
president can understand he's got to
stand up for the ER a when when the
members of his union don't agree with
them when when Republicans can learn
that message in reverse we've got
something to talk about but the contract
with America is devoid of anything
meaningful that will get the social
conservatives activated and they're
starting to look at things like the US
taxpayers party in Howard Phillips and
and and others because they're so upset
with the lack of any meaningful
advancement on their fronts they're
willing to be good foot soldiers and
help out on the other fronts on the
Front's of you know
sure we believe in lower taxes sure we
believe in the others other things but
those are way down the list of
importance and I think it's school
choice school choice but where's the
advance but where have we made it a real
gain on school choice it's not an
unimportant Ohio Wisconsin in a gross
mistake let's hang with the state level
I'm talking bout in Congress that's
focus of our panel I thought we are not
making any advancements on the issues
that really matter to the twenty to
thirty percent of the of the workers of
the party that go out and ring the
doorbells stuff the envelopes and so on
and I think we've got a real rebellion
on our hand there they're basically the
Pro element within the Republican Party
they really don't care about
republicanism they care about these
group of issues and they want some
advancement osteo and forgive me for not
knowing the answer but how do you come
out on NAFTA and GATT and the World
Trade Organization so there's enough I
thought that was a very interesting
aspect of the Republican convention by
the way was the about every four
speeches there was an attack on on the
UN it seems to me that having denied the
delegates the red meat of the unborn
child
the the the issue for the the deep
throated raw was some the red army and
blue berets or whatever it is from the
mr. Welch's blue book that was informing
very very strongly to to see birth Jean
Kirkpatrick and George Bush joining in
the denigration of the UN I thought but
no I wanted to say but if as I
understand the Gingrich in view of the
content of America it's a free market
one and a free trade one and that seems
to me a much more interesting
potentially important split between the
Gingrich in and the Buchanan I'd views
though on social conservative matters it
doesn't seem to me there's that much of
a discrepancy between them but you see
this concerns me a lot because 1994
Republicans did something I hadn't done
in 40 years and it was just it was a
landslide there's nothing short of a
landslide and a shock to virtually
everyone who was watching but 1994
happened because the Perot style
Republican voted for the same candidate
as the Christian Coalition style
Republican who voted for the same
candidate
the moderate establishment Republican
and I am afraid and I listen to what you
say and I'm afraid that actually even
though you talk unity you're actually
seeking to pull this whole coalition
apart that there has to be room in the
Republican Party for Ralph Reed and John
Warner that there has to be room in
image if it's to remain a majority
Republican party because the Democrats
won in the 50s and the 60s because the
segregationists and the intricate
integrationists voted for the same
candidates because on other issues they
agreed if you want to tear the party
apart fine but then it will only be a
45% party it won't be a 51% party well
you misunderstand my import then the the
way you tear a party apart is to behave
like john warner is when you have
republican nominees for office you go
out and openly oppose that you're back
in john warner now I am then that I
stand corrected corrected more
technically but the the you know cuz I
took an oath as a Republican activist to
support my party and I I've done that I
did it the day after he won the
nomination when I had supported Jim
Miller in the nomination contest and so
the way you win offices is you back your
party's nominee and and my complaint is
this is we don't deliver on our promises
to to the social conservatives we tell
you yeah we're going to go out and and
do something about the National
Endowment for the Arts
they make speeches about it they don't
deliver they make speeches on the
Department of Education they don't
deliver and and when they make speeches
about party unity and when the social
conservative wins the nomination
they trouts him and the failure of the
Republican Senatorial community to back
woody Jenkins right now in Louisiana is
a crime he is the Republican nominee for
the party in Louisiana and the
Senatorial Committee will not back him
because of this crazy Democrat
controlled the system down there the
real reason I believe that they're not
backing what he Jenkins is what he's the
social conservatives he's a great
candidate and and the establishment of
the republican party's got to wake up
and realize they're alienating a good
portion of their base if they want us to
be loyal
it's got to be loyalty return
unity requires a two-way street that's
what I'm asking for is a two-way street
here there's a be loyal to us as we've
been welcomed that's intriguing contrast
to what we were saying about the decline
of party Allegiance and identification
is it not I mean I it it's nothing to me
really but I must say it I'm astounded
when the when I hear a publican say that
the the 10th phrase I wouldn't mind not
hearing again should have room for
Oliver North but not for Colin Powell I
just don't see how that can be made to
come out right but as I say I'm happy
there's not my problem however the I
think you're wrong by axiom in saying
that your first duty is to support your
own party we wouldn't have Bill Clinton
as president in my submission if it
wasn't for Democrats for Nixon in 1972
which incidentally was a group mainly
added to the Texas Democratic Party
which Clinton was then working for down
in Texas with Taylor branch near those
who having defeated McGovern and thrown
in with Nixon became the Democratic
Leadership Council which became the
comeback of lesser even ISM that we all
enjoy today in other words the you know
that that I suppose must be the one of
the moral origins a triangulation okay
let's turn to Democratic divisions for a
minute
Irving Kristol said in the last panel
that Clinton was going to move sharply
left if reelected do you agree with that
and then and if not or if so what does
that mean for the Democrats in the house
at least since night just to answer Mr
crystals point I think at least since
that experience in Texas in 1972 mr.
Clinton has been self-consciously
moving himself and hoping to move the
country to the right and has done so in
ways I think that know their Republican
leader could have hoped to do no I
couldn't I mean I hope we'll get some
questions on the floor from that as to
the nature and character of the party um
I have this a pursue if it's if I can
call it that
partly to Murray Kempton we're having
conversations San Diego said you know
the Democratic Party used to be a bunch
of pretty tough minded white Southerners
who were appealing to the loyalties and
the emotions of Catholics and Jews and
who knew how to keep the blacks more or
less in their places said well they've
they've lost all that completely said
Mary with note of regret in his voice
but look how the Republicans are
masterfully reproducing the idea of a
party run by tough-minded white
Southerners that excessively appeals to
the aspirations and emotions of at least
of native-born Catholics I mean I think
they fall down on immigrant ones a bit
or have a tendency to do so and so forth
now the words that the Democratic
convention you know if it weren't for
the welfare type delegates who we heard
about in the preceding session and the
moral energy is they see it of the
pro-choice forces the would be very hard
to think of what really got them going
do you see significant democratic
cleavages the gore versus the Gephardt
wings for example i don't think in terms
of their core constituency the building
blocks of the Democratic Party that
they've got a disagreement you've got
the big city machines you've got the
trial lawyers you have the labor unions
you have government workers you have
both wings of the dependency movement
people who are locked into welfare and
the people who make $80,000 a year
making sure everybody stays locked into
dependency and doesn't escape and become
a Republican but that that group they
all share agreement on key issues what
the problem they have is if the
Republicans are able to successfully say
no tax increase no more money and then
everybody in that group who makes a
living off of taxpayer funds starts to
look at everybody else's lunch because
because there's no incoming tax support
and that's why I think the Democrats
were willing to throw welfare reform
over the over the side because they were
defending all of the other spending
interests that they had in mind and the
same thing with freedom to farm which I
think was a strategic error for the
Democrats but the question of what
Clinton would do in a second term I
think in the last two years his model
has been Richard Nixon in the early
seventies sitting and moving over to the
to the right is Nixon move to the left
and absorb too much of the of the
democratic party's agenda undermining
the Nixon the Republicans during Nixon
years and the second Clinton term would
look a lot like a second Nixon term
largely because with the Republican
Congress
because he has all the same problems
Nixon
in terms of what subpoenas and
indictments can do to everybody's
standing near you and a second Clinton
term with a Democratic Congress what
would that look like then I think he'd
lurch lurch to the left because the
Democratic Party has been shorn of its
moderate or conservative wings to the
extent that there were moderate or
conservative Democrats they lost in 92
and 94 and they resigned this time I
mean they there there isn't in the in
the House of Representative a
conservative Democrat Frank would you
agree with Grover's view of how Clinton
will operate with a Republican Congress
if that's what we have well again flip I
want to take the prospect of the second
question West which was the Democratic
Congress we've done a lot of polling
Francophile Union members can you
imagine what would happen if Bill
Clinton got elected with a Democratic
House and Democratic Senate the people
who would stand up and claim the
greatest victory in which shout and
demand power would be the very people
who have the least power right now the
Sweeney's and the Macan tease organized
labor because they've spent more money
they really have dug deep into the
Treasuries and bet their whole this is
betting on 36 red in roulette they've
taken all the money and all the effort
gone after about 35 40 members in a
serious fashion this is no joke unlike
the Democrats did they say they're going
to target 50 people and then they don't
do the media by when a union person when
someone from the afl-cio says that
they've targeted one of my clients I
know there's going to be hundreds of
thousands of dollars of ads if they take
the majority they will with some
legitimacy be able to stand up and say
we delivered it to you because when
everybody else was silent and when the
Republicans are off the air we took the
money and we put it where it counted and
we knocked off some of these weak
Republicans you owe us and here they go
from being virtually powerless in the
business community to running the
political show for the Democrats what do
you think the top three items on their
agenda would be every to undo everything
that's been done over the last two years
will be a start probably to arrest in
court martial
Gingrich maybe house-arrest the labor
laws in this country will look atrocious
within two years it would be scary but I
think that it's something that people
have to take into account over the next
two months
you mentioned speaker Gingrich he's been
a lot less vocal a lot less visible in
the last six months with a Clinton
presidency and a Republican Congress
how does speaker Gingrich operate in
that new environment that environment
again the same way I think yeah like the
last two years I mean they'll sit there
and they will salami sliced the welfare
state down the way the Democrats salami
sliced it up during the Nixon and Ford
and Reagan years
well they touch Medicare yes I believe I
absolutely believe that there will be a
solution to Medicare whether if Clinton
gets reelected and Republicans still
keep the house in the Senate there will
be a solution to Medicare in the next
Congress because even Bill Clinton can't
look at that and say i'ma let it go even
further the system is going back up so
quickly that I believe he's got at least
that much integrity that he would make
the changes that have to be made I don't
think he has that much integrity and I I
do think you would allow a train wreck
all the time arguing
somebody else is responsible I thought
the article on the the puff piece and
the front page of the Washington Post a
a few days ago or a few weeks ago about
Clinton desiring to be historic will
tell us a lot about what he would do if
there's a Democratic Congress that lets
him do what he wants to do I think he
will he will try to think of some
radical issues that he can really move
the country toward his and Hillary's
agenda in a meaningful way I am a friend
of Mike Huckabee's the governor of
Arkansas and Mike is known Clinton for a
long time from from his youth and he
said that Clinton really isn't
interested in politics he just wanted to
be famous he would have been equally
happy to been Elvis and and and III need
that same way bro yeah there's a whole
you know it's the whole deal the the
problem is that I think that what
Clinton imagines that would be historic
for him to accomplish this year 2000
thing and all of his new-age thinking
got Hilton Head Island and all this I
think he will do something dramatic
and do something far to the left of the
American public if he's allowed a
lame-duck term so Republican Congress
with a Republican Congress of course you
can you can't accomplish nearly as much
but I can't believe that the Republican
leadership so letting them have a vote
today on the gay rights bill in the US
Senate so you know sometimes they
surprise me it doesn't get to decide
what you have votes on in the Senate
under Senate rules well Christopher you
got a point
I was adopted with the with the
president I what I keep kept wishing
earlier on this might I be in the first
session as well I can tell you about the
inhaling thing yes it was because you
could the president's allergic to smoke
but unfortunately no one it could be
baked into cookies which he's always had
a pronounced fondness and the technical
truth of that of that loyal Eli of his
is one that has never ceased to
fascinate me
I think that's probably the thing that
my friend and former landlord John
O'Sullivan the editor of the National
Review is just written a piece it's a
really it's a real howl of despair he's
saying we have to find some right
witness who's the engine hasn't stolen
yet and he checks off ticks of all ones
that he has stolen for him to move up to
where Johnny Sullivan now is all he has
to do I think is come up English only
for a complete ban on affirmative action
and probably make a stand against
hyphenated America which is something I
think Clinton would find it very easy to
do running against yes very much so I
mean just mush it's much too easy to say
you know we're all Americans first and
that kind of thing and I think would I
think the thing he most wishes he had
said of the things that have been said
in the recent past is Gingrich's idea of
a computer on every desk in school I
think that's exactly what Clinton thinks
oh there's a new idea I think that's
what he wishes he'd said first I think
his image of the of the millennium is of
an America that's practically
ideologically neutral where politics is
only management where the country is
competitive where it's stripped down and
leaned for for new technology the new
challenges and all of that that's that's
what he likes
that's what you do there is no chance at
all that he'll move for the left and I
may say there's no chance whatever we
pushed there by the afl-cio they can
spend all the money they like on him and
he can still tell the man will as he has
in the past where I'll see you thinking
of going if I tell you to get lost
jonathan tasini is a very good writer on
labor matters through an extremely good
book on the decline of American labor
called the edifice complex when Sir the
one of the one of the main reasons for
the long run secular decline of American
labor is it has spent all its money on
unrewarding Democratic candidates
instead of on organizing and recruiting
that's precisely the mistake Larry that
is the condition of the political defeat
so I couldn't ready to severe with you
more on that how do you see the speaker
speaker Gingrich behaving in a second
Republican Congress a second Republican
Congress with with Clinton reelected I
think he would think as he has in the
past all his birthday's have come at
once
I mean I've certainly heard people in
his entourage say this is the outcome
that they must hope for just as I've
heard people in the president's suite
saying that that the you know their big
moment came when when mr. Gingrich
cleaned out the Democratic Deadwood from
the house I think just the understanding
that is the beginning of wisdom of a man
wonderful comments from the panelists
thus far we'd like to open this to your
questions does anyone have a question
who would like to begin yes in the back
I think can you wait for the c-span mic
to come around okay
like to direct this to Frank if I could
um I wonder out of the the afl-cio 35
races they're targeting how many of
those freshmen Republican I guess from
mainly freshman Republican are likely
not to be back next section to make next
year out of the seventy-three how many
are likely not to be very bad
well they've targeted virtually every
freshman that has any chance of being
defeated so I only say 3540 because
those are the ones that they've really
truly gone after but in some ways
they've targeted about seventy seats I
am an optimist I don't know if I'm as
much of an optimist as Grover my guests
if I had to predict now would be that
about half a dozen of those seats that
were won in 1994 were won because of the
wave and maybe giving back and I'm
unwilling to specify which ones but I
think for the most part they will win
for this reason they went back to their
districts weekend after weekend they
campaigned face to face door-to-door I
can think of one Randy Tate well I'm
told is now up to about 50,000 voters in
his district that he has met on
Saturdays and Sundays just shaking hands
and talking to them that's incredible
this freshman class forget the politics
forget the rhetoric on a personal basis
has actually gone out and worked harder
than any other class in modern
congressional history they care about
what they do and they're prepared to
dedicate their lives it's not been good
on their family life there have been a
few that have had some families come
apart but they are prepared to do what
it takes to get to know their
constituents to shake the hands meet and
greet and so I don't see more than half
a dozen being defeated what how would
you protect that I think that's probably
accurate one of the challenges the
Democrats have is not just that the
Republicans went back and worked hard
what the demo what the Republicans did
what the Democrats did in 1974 after the
Watergate babies came in was they ramped
up the amount of spending that each of
the incumbents had they ramped up the
franked mail and so on so they
entrenched themselves using taxpayer
resources this
freshman class came in and actually cut
all of that stuff cut cut staff cut
franking limited what they were allowed
to do and so they were forced to go out
and work very very hard on their own
they they didn't rely on franked mail
and and nothing and so on just as the
democrats did to ride through that first
year they have worked hard the democrats
have had a very bad year in terms of
recruitment up against Randy Tate they
have a guy named Adam Smith who ran
promising to support term limits and
then double-crossed his constituents and
was an opponent of term limits this in a
heavily Perot district so you've got a
guy who's whose central claim to fame is
they lied to people on on term limits as
your challenger in run against Phil
English in Pennsylvania they're running
an LA lawyer who's still based in LA
whose car and registration are in two
different states and who's as a lawyer
has been representing all sorts of
unsavory characters so one of the
challenges you have whenever you're
trying to to run new people challengers
and the Democrats have to find 73 new
people to run is you sometimes get
people with big big problems that didn't
show up in primaries so some of their
best opportunities you would think for
pickups they've they've they've been
stuck with very bad candidates in terms
of overall I think the Republicans will
will add to their numbers largely
because of the 20 open seats that the
Democrats have that are that are weak
Democratic seats I think particularly in
the south the Democrats are going to
lose an awful lot of those open seats
and start not with a 19 or 20 Republican
margin that the Democrats have to
overcome but more like 30 or 35 simply
because those open seats are breaking so
strongly to the Republicans other
questions Grover you mentioned term
limits let's talk about the potency of a
lot of issues we've we've heard about
term limits gay marriage partial birth
abortion to start Grover I think several
interesting things on term limits the
Republicans came in delivered the
Republican vote for term limits in the
house but didn't
the two-thirds necessary for the
constitutional amendment and some
term-limit advocates have done oh no we
didn't get everything we wanted on term
limits if you look at what the
Republicans did in the house immediately
first day and then in in the Senate they
term limited committee chairmen so
anybody in the house with extra power
his term limits speaker Gingrich is term
limited to eight years every Committee
Chairman is term limited to six and then
the Senate came in later in term limited
their committee meant as well and one of
the things that that's done is that it's
turned the people who would be opponents
of change into radicals you had Archer
they had now the head of the Ways and
Means Committee immediately walks in
he's term limited to six years he says
let's get rid of the IRS and go to a
sales tax I don't think that's what most
people thought that Archer would do upon
becoming chairman Pat Roberts becomes in
charge of the Agriculture Committee
where you would think is the number one
the the locus of opposition to reforming
farm subsidies what does he do he says
well I'm leaving this job in six years
let's phase-out farm subsidies and they
passed the freedom to farm legislation
so term limits has led to a a more
radical worldview by just the kinds of
people who because their committee
chairmen in the past would have been the
opponents of change so when you've term
limited everybody with more power than
their one vote you've had a tremendous
impact on but how the house works and
we'll begin to see it in the Senate
shortly like you talked about the
Republican Party being pro gun earlier
dole has said that he opposes repeal of
the assault weapons ban do you disagree
with that and if so is that going to
hurt the party and its core constituency
as you see it well I it certainly
doesn't help anything
i side of that issue do you think yeah I
think that I think that doles on the
wrong side of the issue I think the
Republican Party as a whole is on the
right side of the issue but you know
it's it's a matter of mislabelling the
weapons first of all but I don't want to
get into debate on on the substance of
it but there is a strong constituency in
this country that believes in the Second
Amendment they
that that we need to stand by it and
people just don't like waffles if you
say one thing and then you switch your
mind all the time
that's the deadliest sin in politics
Christopher partial birth abortions or
gay marriage of course certain limits
first I mean I'm sure that some Jenna
Burlinson I think is not running again
which I'm sorry for made to me the point
that I'll pass on to you I seem to be
being the ventriloquist for all kinds of
other people today but they're the
dummies role if you've got term limits
to be the only people who really know
how the place works will be the
lobbyists I mean I think that's a point
that's not made often enough there will
be there will be people who there for
very brief time dressing a little brief
Authority totally at the mercy of the
Sharks I think it's a point worth barium
I'd also think it's quite plainly
flat-out unconstitutional and it would
be struck down but I like the idea
because it might help to counteract
bills and spell prediction but that
those committee chairmanships could be
limited because I think it I think it is
the the internal incrustation of the
institution that people are trying to
that's the plaque people are trying to
break down when they when they call for
what I think is otherwise a demagogic
populist solution and foolish on the
other side of term limits is that now
there are 2,000 state legislators in the
country who are term limited and so
every six and eight years you're turning
out competent well-funded well-known
state senators and state representatives
who can become serious challengers to
people who are the incumbents either of
their own party or of somebody else's
party so term limits have both term
limited the committee chairs up top and
they've term limited a third of the
state legislators underneath and they're
really putting some pressure on Congress
itself and you'll see a more turnover
among congressmen even if you don't get
a constitutional amendment on term
limits for sitting members of Congress
of course a constitutional amendment
can't be unconstitutional by definition
so if there is a constitutional it's
impossible to strike it down avoiding
the partial-birth class
I think the the irony for the pro-choice
people most of whom are in temper and
character secular and consider
themselves to be you know scientific in
approach and civil is that it's
precisely the advance of medical science
and in particular of embryology that has
totally redefined what anyone has to
agree is the meaning of the viability of
an unborn child earlier and earlier and
more and more and I think I think
probably the sonogram is the thing that
has done done the most to recruit
support for the for the pro-life cause
the the partial birthing is another of
those areas here's a procedure that
wouldn't have been possible to do till
recently probably I must say it looks as
if everyone involved would have died
instead but they why it's and it's
another illustration of how science is
in effect confirming the idea of the
unborn child and I think that a number
of exactly the sort of Catholic voters
who were worried about the welfare
question for example who feared that it
was too harsh on the poor and indeed
might lead to a more desperate resort to
abortion on the bottom poor people and
have had worries of that kind Democratic
warriors you might say but who are loyal
to their church really felt that Clinton
could have given them something on this
and and and are very very distressed
that he's not right before you leave
issues one that's not going to hit this
year but it's bubbling under and it's
going to explode
his education Americans are
fundamentally disgusted with the shape
of public schools right now they have
frustrated whether they think their kids
are not being taught effectively if at
all they don't like what they are
learning if they learn anything in the
schools we almost an almost blue with
what Lynne Cheney was trying to do in
challenging some of these national
standards that the history exams are
what they were talking about the things
that would be taught in school it is so
close it's going to take one political
person a couple months or some major
crises in a in a school system but it is
right underneath the surface every time
a Republican or Democrat talked about it
at either convention the reaction was
more
positive than anything else except
eliminating the IRS what do people think
of it primarily as a federally I mean
they think of it primarily the state and
local issue but you say it's going to
clean up to the federal that's the
challenge the Democrats are in very bad
shape if they want to be against school
choice the Republicans are going to have
a problem when it gets to the financial
issue because most Americans do believe
the more money you spend the better the
education you get we know that that's
not the truth but it will be very hard
for Republicans to deal with it because
it is a state local issue it's gonna be
very hard for the Democrats to deal with
it because they're in the pocket of the
NEA who was against merit pay against
merit schools against the reforms that
virtually every American supports though
it was forgotten or perhaps let us say
overlooked I thought when dole threw
down that gauntlet to the teachers union
in his speech it as I remember that's
how Clinton got his sort of political
star tonight and so we're going to
attract the attention of the DLC types
was precisely by taking on the teachers
union in his home state I think this is
an issue on which he's pulling quite
maneuverable oh the interesting thing is
that Americans do not when they hear
about teachers unions they hear their
word teacher they don't hear the word
Union it's the one union in America that
Americans still feel remotely positively
towards that's also going to be if you
want to get rid of your Department of
Education you got to start by explaining
to Americans what the NEA and the AFT
and all those groups are and what they
do I think you have to explain to
Americans that only so many people could
make a decision about a child if they
want their child to have a person that
loves them and cares about them making
the decisions as opposed to some remote
bureaucrat getting rid of the Department
of Education puts the decision-making
back in that teachers hands and in the
school board's hand the parents hands
that that's the way to explain and when
education also happens to be the best
education policy it's not just good
politics it's right for kids and I think
that when Republicans understand how to
explain that issue to people it's a very
much of a winning issue I think also
related to that's the issue of parents
rights that's going to be on the ballot
in Colorado it has over 80% positive
rating among people the voters and I
think it's a case of the Village People
vs parents you know the it takes a
village to raise a child crowd and
it's it's it's better than the village
idiots it's more kind but the that what
they mean by the village is an army of
bureaucrats and and there's a
fundamental distrust of all these
so-called professionals among parents
these days
and they think that their instincts are
better than than the professionals and
they're right and we need to have
empower parents by getting the
bureaucrats off their backs we have a
question here wait for the mic I think
television ads with congressional
candidates now first a comment from
Carlin Bowman on the current negative
positives of the president and the
speaker and then some observations from
Frank Luntz
on how that's playing out around the
nation to the extent that Republicans
are using the president and TV ads and
how it's working to the extent the
Democrats are using the speaker in TV
ads and how that's working and if there
seems to be a disparity there well you
have probably newer numbers than I do
but the president's favorable rating is
one of the highest of his presidency in
the latest Gallup poll it's 61 percent
favorable overall I think that is the
the highest for Gallup on that question
Gingrich's ratings remain overwhelmingly
negative I don't know I don't have any
current numbers on that but Freddie is
four points higher than the Unabomber so
the the Democrats are trying to use
Gingrich as a foil and it is not working
it did not work it has not worked in
these open seat races and it's very
unlikely that it will work because the
Speaker of the House is something
distant people still feel that their
member of Congress isn't is their member
of Congress something local something
that they can relate to something they
can touch and now more than ever that
they've been back at home much more
often there is a greater relationship
the generic ballot numbers the most
recent ones are not good for the GOP and
yet when you ask the question are you
going to vote for your member or you're
gonna vote for the Challenger the
numbers that I've seen show that people
actually want to vote for their members
for their incumbent Newt Gingrich is a
distant figure he is not their speaker
of the house he's something that's
that's a way that's in Washington
so the strategy inherently is flawed I
don't blame them for using it because we
tried it ourselves it's one thing to use
it against the president in 1994 because
he is the present United States to do
the morphing it does not work as well
when it is a speaker of the house the
positions are different incumbent
favorability ratings are very high right
now surprisingly high I think overall
and so you may actually see the biggest
divergence between re-election rates for
Republicans and generic ballot that you
have seen at any time in recent American
history
not that you've asked me but I just want
to go through them
it used to be speculated in the Reagan
Bush years that there was a sort of
version of cognitive dissonance among
the electorate in that they liked to
have a president who was tough on the
communists and strong national security
and stand up for American or that kind
of thing and then when it came to the
House and Senate they wanted to make
sure there were sort of furry Democrats
who would keep the various checks and so
on coming and that this was their their
sort of pact with themselves and each
other could it be that this is now sort
of being inverted this dissonance and
that they want a president who does that
and House members and senators who do
the opposite it's just a thought he's
running as isn't here's a bit of a sort
of as rather avuncular and partly
parental partly school probably
headmaster Lee I mean we asked the pain
feed pain feeling all that in a focus
Europe we asked where whose bill can
remind you of someone said the Pillsbury
Doughboy everybody likes the Pillsbury
Doughboy actually reminds me of the guy
this that always wants your bud you know
and he's the ultimate come on and I
think the Republicans could run a very
clever ad by saying I'm sorry bill
you're just ain't getting my vote to to
mimic those those great Budweiser ads do
we have any other questions yes I
my understanding of the 94 election was
that the Republicans turned out nine
million new voters and the Democrats
only went down by 1 million how do you
see that turning out for 96 I had to
make I always like to try one projection
for each time I do this and my
projection is that 1996 will be the
lowest turnout in modern presidential
history that we won't do what we did in
92 which was reverse I mean 92 was a
significant increase over 88 94 was the
sickest the highest turnout an off-year
since 82
96 I think we're back down to 50% maybe
even down as low as 49% and turnout yeah
one question back there mr. Harris
raises the question about the other NEA
National Endowment for the Arts I wanted
to ask mister luntz if he has any
polling data it seems that that is no
longer a hot-button issue and so do you
have any data about that and anyway
anyone might comment on what a dull arts
policy might be the funny thing is
Americans want a balanced budget but
when you itemize specific programs they
don't want to cut anything we went and
did a whole lot of programs and relative
to virtually everything else is there to
be chopped
that one scored very high but still
you've got it's got a small constituency
that thinks that you can balance the
budget without cutting anything any
other comments on the
no I just think if the Republicans get
the presidency in the House and the
Senate that you'll see budget restraint
across the board said that you'll see
less government spending on that issue
and out of another issue but I don't
think that under the current formulation
you'll see an elimination of it we all
talk Tenth Amendment but show me in the
Constitution where we have the authority
to spend the money on the National
Endowment for the Arts it's just not
there one final question right and
that's proved to be so low this year
what is the electrical consequence of
that who's hurt most by that I don't see
any intensity for Bill Clinton even with
this wide support that he's got right
now the intensity of people who just
cannot wait to get out and vote for him
is almost nil because even people who
are voting for him recognize his
weaknesses and they're very quick to
point it out in fact the interesting
thing with Bill Clinton is that even his
own voters sit there and they talk about
why they don't like him but then they
still plan to vote for him and the
intensly for the Republicans that
existed in 1994 is not there to the same
degree because it's like been there done
that so the intensity on both sides has
decreased significantly while the
frustration among those people right in
the middle the Perot types has actually
increased and whereas they turned out in
92 and 94 I don't think you're gonna
have that same level turnout 96
therefore it's a wash on both sides and
he hasn't created any Clinton Republican
associate now you saw the woman who held
up the banner saying Republicans were
Clinton the other day at his rally and
he said I wish I could sign that and
really embrace you and so on I don't
know whether she was a plant or not but
if she wasn't she's she's not the
harbinger of anything there are no
Clinton Republicans not that you can see
yet Frank you made a prediction let's
have one final prediction a sleeper race
a Republican Congress a Democratic
Congress let's say the rest of you make
a prediction about the House or Senate
House Republicans pick up 14 seats and
three seats in the Senate
mic well I'll just make a generic
prediction they took I think that where
you see clear-cut social conservatives
they will do better than the the squishy
middle-of-the-road Republicans
Christopher we have an electro that
wants it both ways and can and can have
it to add will I'd like to thank on
behalf of the American Enterprise
magazine that like this great country or
isn't it hmm thank all of our panelists
for participating in Scott do you have a
word or two to convert thank you Harlan
and also the panelists as I say the
edited transcript of the talks today
will be available in the next issue of
the American Enterprise magazine for
those of you who want to follow up on
the talk about education there's our
current issue that's out now and that
you can get a free copy of by calling